right I've got the thumb
I think it's all system
go cool ok let's get started
my name is Don I am F sharp contributor
I originally started the f-sharp
language design yeah I have Microsoft
Research in Cambridge it around 2003 I
contributed to c-sharp 2.0 as well and
it's great to be here at NTC you might
detect a slight Australian hint in my
accent maybe it comes back a little more
strongly as I as I come home originally
born and bred Queenslander in Queensland
in the audience yes go Broncos
and yeah wonderful to be back in
Australia to reconnect that respect with
the deaf community here which didn't
really exist back in 1994 when I packed
bags and headed to England to do my PhD
it wasn't quite the same so the tech
wasn't the same as it is now you're
leaving a great time here in Australia
where there are communities like this
and worldwide that you can participate
in and you hopefully live in a great
time that you can use programming
technologies that have improved
dramatically since the days since the
early nineties when I was living here
and what are those programming
technologies you get to use dotnet and
one of the languages here to use on.net
you and your teams is f sharp and I'm
very happy to have been part of bringing
that to to practical fruition now I've
been thinking about like what what am I
actually doing when I give this talk I
said f sharp code I love it's actually
the one of the funny things about this
talk it's sort of several
meta-narratives underneath it right like
like most talks or most talks I give
anyway and a very large part of this
talk is actually aimed at at c-sharp
developers in factual or aimed at you
can imagine there are teams who are
using a sharp where a lot of the people
who come to use F sharp you know they're
not actually learn it on the on the job
ok they they just so we often see this
that the best way
- hi Rochelle developers is the higher
good sous-chef developer and just let
him riff and use their sharp and learn
as they go it's not very hard but
something happens in those teams which
is which is important in that sometimes
there are people who are extremely
gung-ho about f-sharp i extremely
gung-ho about functional programming and
they might have a lot of obscure
language that they use the most cure to
obscure terminology they might write
code that looks very different to other
people's code they might cause arguments
between those teams and and in some ways
that's not a good that's not a good
healthy thing and nor does it have to be
like that and so I would have given this
talk in the past often the people who
come up to me after the talk are
actually the ones in the team who want
to rein in the use of some parts of
either F sharp F sharp or perhaps F
sharp people who want to rein in their
more extreme edges of object-oriented
programming so I want to kind of take
the extremities of C sharp programming
practice and F sharp programming
practice and push them out a little bit
and focus on this sort of core part of F
sharp which is the F sharp code well I
love and which is embodied in in what we
think of this good positive F sharp
practice and and so that's really kind
of the meta-narrative underneath the
talk for those of you who don't do F
sharp or expose to some parts some small
amounts of F sharp programming or you're
not gonna functional people but you're
in a you're in an F sharp programming
team and and that's also aimed at the
gung-ho F sharp people to think about
you know how where do we want to land
the the methodology and practice of F
sharp coding okay so I'm going to do
that that's a meta-narrative i'm not
going to make that explicit
from now on but it's really a code to
walk through some of the code I love
some of the code I don't like I love a
little less and then sort of talk about
how it relates to the actual language
design someone asked me last night what
makes a good programming language and I
found it
giving like a 10-minute spiel which
wasn't at all answering the question but
telling a completely different story
which is there are two big streams of
programming which come together in
languages like F sharp and C sharp these
days and these streams of history of in
the history of program they go all the
way back to in the world I've been out
in Cambridge right back to like 1950
when they made these first machines and
they were the people who actually made
the machines and then there were the
logicians okay there were the Alan
Turing's actually fiddled and made with
the actual machines and there were the
people like Church who sort of made the
the abstract kind of world of
computation there the lambda calculus of
maleic and these two communities really
literally person-by-person over the
years grew up into sort of the world of
imperative programming and the world of
functional programming roughly roughly
speaking and and so a good programming
language is is one well for me the aim
has always been to take the core ideas
of functional programming and make them
really fly in practice in in in in in
the practical world and they're written
in the real world connecting them
through to the real world and so that
that that that's what it to me making a
good programming language is all about
both in c-sharp and an f-sharp and you
can kind of see sous chef knife shop as
being too kind of partners in that game
one is taking an imperative programming
language tradition and incorporating the
functional elements into it one is
tasting a functional programming
language tradition and connecting it
through the dotnet and through the data
sources in reality okay if you want to
hear more about my ideas on history of
programming languages history of F sharp
is Lord about the history of net and
c-sharp where those kind of traditions
meet there's a this this is available
it's a 40-page great rock and roll read
of the history all the way through the
80s and 90s and early 2000s up to about
2012 a shelf that looks like slash
history
lots of characters make make an
appearance along the way
until I tell the story two stories one
of the world of Microsoft and they're
sort of worldwide domination of the
computing industry and another one of
the story of the functional programming
academics and and and they're sort of
the the small band of of zealots or
devotees who who made functional
programming sort of practical in the 80s
and 90s through the languages like
Haskell and oh camel and then how these
kind of both of these worlds got kind of
wiped out by this tsunami of
object-oriented programming you know
Java hid the world and Mark soft almost
like well he got into a lot of trouble
legally and what if they sort of did
admits responses to the world of
object-oriented programming so of the
donated programming sort of hit even
something as big as the worldwide drug a
lot of Microsoft and they'll also hit
that world of academics a functional
programming those those logicians I
couldn't quite work out how to integrate
this object-oriented programming thing
into their worldview and and they had
all these different reactions to what to
do about this integration and things
like Scala come from that I list out all
the different ways I saw people reacting
to this kind of problem this sort of
dialectic kind of problem of these
things that don't fit together and how
can we how can we make a synthesis that
actually improves things and and and
integrates things and you can see that
playing through all the way through to
today in c-sharp 8.06 1/2 9.0 they're
still basically playing the same script
okay how do we take the ideas from
functional get them into c-sharp makes
them really fly and you can see it in in
in F sharp it continues today so check
out the F sharp that'll slash history
and there is still time to send me
feedback on that if you've got some more
bits and pieces you'd like to
incorporate in that right ok this is an
opinion talk and lucky I get to give
that oh ok so what is f sharp first a
couple of about 10 slides on where we're
at with F sharp this is how Microsoft
described F sharp and the open source
cross-platform functional language for
net those of you I don't do any dot
all I can think it was Scala is to Java
f-sharp is to c-sharp and it has
fantastic interoperability with c-sharp
fantastic performance can use things
like asp.net core if you used giraffe
the when the the the f-sharp web
programming DSL that sits on top of
asp.net core you get a really beautiful
functional Eric functional first web
programming stack for the server side
and so all the wonderful things that are
happening and on that core or flow up
through through F sharp as well and you
can use all of those but F sharp is not
just what Microsoft says it is it's an
interesting thing and I'll talk a bit
more about this from a community
perspective because F sharp is actually
a JavaScript language as well a strong
JavaScript language where this this tool
called fable and also another one called
web sharper they're both excellent F
sharp to JavaScript systems fable is
interesting because it is really
positioned as a part of the JavaScript
ecosystem you install it and getting it
getting started with it is just with NPM
it's not yeah you actually barely know
you're doing any dotnet programming at
all it's much more like typescript F
sharp sort of feels like it's yeah using
an S or typescript kind of mode and you
get the high pretty high quality looking
clean JavaScript out the other end and
and as I said it's part of the ecosystem
so if you're a JavaScript are at a
front-end developer you will actually
feel quite at home in the fable
community it's a separate community in a
way use their sharp as the language has
its own conferences for example recently
an antral conference through its third
third conference so but part of the
important thing here is what microsoft
says their shop is but because the way
if shop is built and delivered it can
also be a javascript language and this
is a very much a community point of view
on what f-sharp is and that's kind of
because f sharp isn't quite as we really
let the community own the message about
F sharp I mean Microsoft is part of that
community and says you know we are quite
open we make and contribute to F sharp
because it is good for our
a cloud platform that's why we do not
donate as well because ultimately we are
cloud platform provider as well as other
things but dotnet is part of as your
program ability effectively and that's
why Microsoft contributed F sharp and F
sharp has a structure through the F
sharp software foundation which is f
sharp that org which is very self
empowered and open across platform
neutral independent of course it's all
open source and accepting contributions
the tooling is also very community
oriented sure there is there is a Visual
Studio Chilean which obviously loads of
people use but there is also the Visual
Studio code to link or iron odd for F
sharp which is all community all
community driven and owned and there's
also the JetBrains trolling in rider
which is great good and high quality as
well quickly running through these you
can use it with xamarin you can use it
with visuals for their code windows/mac
as you can also use it on the other
cloud platforms Google cloud platform
and AWS and of course there's a great
Linux storage through through dotnet
core now one of the reasons why all this
works and one of the reasons f-sharp
could be both a JavaScript language and
a dotnet language is because of the
f-sharp compiler service which is a
single component a single DLL which
powers all of the F sharp tooling and
contains all of the logic of the F sharp
implementation so it's very tight
implementation there's no
re-implementation of F sharp there is
one implementation of F sharp which is
delivered through the F sharp compiler
service component and that's integrated
into all of these I've talked about
fable there's a there's a very wonderful
stack called safe sack that puts
together the F sharp fable JavaScript on
the on the client side and F sharp
Fernet on the server side and you can
share your code back between the front
end and back end and encourage you to
take a look at that if you're into stock
programming and my job is to focus on
the actual language design generally and
that's f-sharp 4.7 we've done I'll just
quickly run through what we've done with
those are not going to run through the
list you could just glance down them
what we've been doing since we really
properly moved to open engineering and
open source I've not only open-source to
a fully augment source open engineering
community oriented engineering just you
can glance through these 4.1 4.5 4.6 4.7
just-released
ok that's how you get started on dotnet
core for those who using a just dotnet
new - Lang F sharp that I've built
that's they're integrated in the.net SDK
anywhere where the dotnet SDK is used
and available then F sharp is also
available for instance most of the cloud
platforms in have the dotnet SDK
installed and available then you can
just use F sharp there as well ok and
this is a brief you know does it really
matter to use a functional first
methodology or not and this is really
key to the value proposition of Y F
sharp is actually bringing value to the
Dom net ecosystem at all if it was just
a shell for the same syntax as c-sharp
it didn't carry really strong either
language properties or library
properties or methodological and kind of
characteristics then it wouldn't be
worth doing it but it does make a big
difference in practice for a
well-functioning F sharp team that is
able it is use it in the right zone can
make is can be exceptionally productive
and accurate in their coding and of
course met it's hard to prove that
categorically and you can always give
anecdotes but this is one I think that I
always refer to because there are
actually quite a lot of things we
actually kept constant between these two
things that were working on the same
problem in the same company and it was a
is roughly c-sharp
maybe 3.0 4.0 or a code so it doesn't
include all of them and it was also done
by an offshore team
rather than it's a what not one in the
UK but the one on the right was done by
a smaller team in the UK so there's a
sushar project with five took five years
about eight developers didn't finish all
the contracts and there was a
simultaneous implementation of that in
the UK by an f-sharp team and a Peter
three developers with less than one year
I think and fully implemented the
contract and a big difference in the
overall like out now you might say why
is there such a big difference well
there are reasons braces are a big
reason yeah lots and lots of lines of
braces there's also a lot of blank lines
yeah proportion blank lines in the air
shaft code to about ten percent in each
there are a lot of null checks in the C
shell code yeah three thousand null
checks that's a lot of places I think
and fail and you can see why C sharp
nine is just you know it's a big part of
the F sharp value proposition or the big
part of the problem with C shaft to be
honest is the pervasive presence of
nulls everywhere utterly needlessly it's
just doesn't serve any role in the vast
majority of programming certainly not in
this kind of place probably the fifteen
places where the F shaft code did null
checks are exactly the places you want
to you want to do them comments good
some comments useful code up code and so
on test code but one thing is very very
telling is this one there were two
thousand try-catch statements in the C
sharp code there were nine I think in
the F sharp code and this is a sign of a
project that's got out of control okay
if you've got two thousand places where
exceptions might be happening and need
to be explicitly caught and handled then
it probably means your developers have
just lost track of the complexity of the
code base and it's just every single
change that they put into the code they
probably try to catch around it just in
case something goes wrong and then they
don't know where to send the exception
to and so
enough with the now I don't know if it's
an asynchronous system you know how they
can get out of control okay Simon
cousins who did this project is
absolutely adamant that F sharp for this
kind of work in the energy industry the
F sharp is totally the safe choice for
doing this kind of work and any other
choice is too risky and he's very very
proud of the zero bugs in a deployed
system for this particular one and he's
achieved that for several of his other
projects as well that doesn't mean
that's going to happen all the time by
any means but he's very good at char
program and uses it well and to say
people have built very valuable
companies on f-sharp comm in America it
was acquired by Walmart for three
billion many people from Australia
actually f-sharp developers their shop
Sydney community got kind of half of
them got hired off to go to New York and
and work for gedcom and we have this
build with F sharp as a service I'd
started using a micro services
architecture and very good and
interesting F sharp code okay just to
say the community community is at the
center of the technology I've touched on
that we have the F job Software
Foundation F sharp dot org right at the
heart of decision making and Microsoft
worked very closely with them and other
and at the center of nearly everything
that happens in the F sharp world but
not in a controlling way but it in an
enabling way and Mattias is in the
audience somewhere yes back there is on
the board of the air shop Software
Foundation and if you're interested in
just talking about like how does the
foundation work what does it mean to be
on a board what does it mean to start a
software foundation or legally how can
you do that door if you have partners in
America for doing that it's actually
it's kind of both easier and harder than
you expect that it can be very
worthwhile part of making a - giving a
technology a good governance and a good
representation independent of its
commercial interests oh it's not secrets
yeah even super great and the community
is at the center of design and
implementation we have the F sharp
language design process we have
suggestions I've got those the wrong way
around
suggestions desire
and in the actual implementation in
the.net foundation repository so we work
with the dotnet foundation there
overlapping foundations in many ways
slightly different yep so you can see
the cooperation is sort of listed out
here actually and the communities at the
centre of tooling I&I a webshop or other
but many other things that happen in the
dot near sharp and Microsoft is part of
this community so how we see ourselves
right but let's talk about code that I
do and don't like and one way to do that
is to go to the community and a great
thing the community does is f-sharp
advent calendar every year and this
usually about 50 or 60 entries written
by people around the world you're very
pleased those those of you doing F sharp
in the audience please contribute to
their shelf have their own calendar to
be honest if you're looking to make the
c-sharp community a better and more
vibrant community start a c-sharp advent
calendar as well yeah I don't know if
there is such a thing I've never seen it
if there is I think it's that kind of
community driven activism is really
missing from the c-sharp world and
considering how vast the c-sharp world
is it should be present so if you're
looking to contribute in the c-shaped
world please do that right but there's
lots of interesting examples of f-sharp
code here it was started by the Japanese
F sharp community back in 2010 and
they've done an amazing job and it's
actually run in 2018 as well in English
there's the original Jefferson Japanese
entries some of them and another way to
work out what is def Java code or doing
don't like is to go back to the
foundations of the f-sharp language
design so back in 2007 when I first
started presenting on f-sharp into this
sort of major audiences inside mark so
if this was one of those slides I used
in the lovely 2007 font kinda are sort
of images but it was the point of
f-sharp was to combine these things that
it yeah one of the statically typed
languages succinct language is scalable
one libraries explorative one that's
interoperable with the world and that
executes efficiently and so that's of
course code that I love
has those characteristics so here's a
example of a tiny bit of code that I
love printf in hello hello world that is
an f-sharp program it's succinct its
expressive and interoperates its
using.net through the libraries performs
well there's no bugs ok so when one of
the great things about a shop is this
pipeline operator to take some value in
you pipe it through some some function
and we see many examples of it being
like chained I've been half of an
f-sharp program is usually code of this
kind and so you'll see for example are
just extracting some parts out of the
f-sharp compiler services or the testing
of it we take the single users we filter
them we do a parallel nap over those we
filter those who group then we map them
it's kind of link style pipeline kind of
way it's but it's a bit different it's a
bit more is like taking the core ideas
of link which are obviously functional
but expanding those out and using from
pretty much half of your code ends up in
this kind of pipeline compositional way
another when you look through the F
sharp advent calendar entries about half
of them are about domain modeling with F
sharp and if you don't know the books
and material boss got well lation domain
modeling made functional I think it's is
the name of the book is a wonderful just
talking why these functional programming
languages that are so good for capturing
the core of these of these domains now
when I started during my PhD when I
started doing this sort of functional
programming it was really dealing it's
actually at a any Australian National
University when I started doing this
sort of thing and it was really dealing
with logic structures that was my domain
ok so we had to represent for instance
the constructs in a circuit
they caught the combinatorial logic in a
circuit and underneath it's like it's
just boolean logic you have and you have
all's you have NAND
XOS you have not you have yeah you just
have a structure a tree a piece of data
if you like representing the the logic
of a circuit and so this was my domain
that I that I would work with and then
you just spend all day long riding your
recursion evaluation normalization
analysis visualization starting with
this core domain and and and they keep
the fact that it's so easy to model that
domain and then adjust the model of it
or in Richert or simplify it as a game
that goes on where you try in some ways
your push to do ultra simplification
down to a very minimal domain sometimes
you also have to augment that with a lot
of real world sort of metadata as well
but it's extremely simple to model the
domain and act as you as you as you
modify it and change it then the type
checking just naturally sort of helps
you adjust the process the parts of your
code that need that need occurs when
interaction adjustment filling in the
cases for the analysis another domain
that I personally work with not one that
you guys Alice you contribute to you
people and let's contribute to the
f-sharp compiler will have to work with
is to do with the optimizer in the
f-sharp compiler and so if you look at
the optimizer and you say well what is
it
domain well it the optimizer has to know
something about F sharp code that it
sees so it can make accurate
optimizations well what does it know it
knows something about an expression and
this is what it knows represents
information knowing about a value it's
other we don't know anything
Val value means it's equal to another
value and we know some more information
so there are Val ref is what it's equal
to and then expression value information
is that extra information and then it
might know it's a tuple that might know
it's a record and so on down so that's
the domain and then once you see that
you can actually more or less predict
what kind of optimizations the F sharp
compiler will or won't do and as you
teach the optimizer more about F sharp
code then the the cases of the
optimization logic kind of drop out so
those are my two
but other people have their domains too
so if you look at Luke Merritt's was a
blog post from the advent calendar and
this is representing the domain of just
different values coming back from a web
request said the system unresponsive
wasn't missing was some valid object and
so on and so that's a simple language
DSL in a way for a modeling of the data
for that domain OD from Nigeria and the
F sharp community it talks about how is
modeling the values he's getting back
from I think this iTunes service and
it's a very kind of similar kind of
thing you know it's getting XML back but
this is the kind of minimal
representation of the information coming
back and he any talks has a very nice
description of how your choice of data
structures is crucial when writing your
code in F sharp if you screw it up if
you get the domain model wrong then
you'll go around in circles that does
happen if you get it right then
all the rest of the code kind of flows
very naturally and this is the book I
mentioned domain modeling made
functional there's also a great book
will get programming with F sharp that
covers some of these domain modeling and
domain semantics topics now one of the
ways people come to F sharp and say ah
dammit F sharp makes you organize your
code from sort of bottom up you know you
write your initial code and then your
main entry method ends up at the bottom
and I want to put it the other way
around but there's a reason we do that
that is of course F sharp it's a
fantastic data scripting language and we
very we want you to orient your code
towards scripts that are like Python
sort of readable down down as things go
down the down the chain so at the top of
your code you have the access to the
data layer we talked about that using a
type provider a bit later and then you
access your your data and then you have
your
and now your extraction your your
loading and extraction of information
from that and f-sharp data scripting is
a really just beautiful thing a
well-written F sharp data script is
extremely clear and and you know crack
some particular data extract load kind
of tasks very nicely okay now and
there's an area I've been working a lot
in lately which has deeply inspired me
about the role of functional programming
in in in practical programming in web in
both Fable web programming and in dotnet
front-end programming and things like
examine for example or WPF and that is
this Model View update architecture for
you is now in this world the key thing
is this view function and this is kind
of the view function for a Model View
update mobile app and the difference
about writing your view in this way is
that the view gets re-evaluated on every
model update and then is that's done in
sort of background and and then a diff
in the react kind of wire diff is made
to the actual Dom elements or the actual
UI elements and what this means is you
you can have very dynamic views that can
depend on things like if model press
then then then we see one view and if we
don't we see another view or for example
in there in the web version of this and
then if we have some text then we say
loading and if once the text has arrived
and we actually fill in the results of
the user interface so this idea that the
view can be a function which takes the
model and generates view elements and
that it is okay to re-evaluate that from
a performance perspective because
there's various various tricks you use
to do that part of this differential
update to the actual UI means that your
whole
program can take a functional approach
now people as interesting being in mark
Siemens talk just now he was kind of
saying well pure functions are kind of
useless because you can't actually do
anything but if those pure functions are
most of your application and then it's
hosted inside an imperative a couple of
imperative things for doing that
differential update then actually nearly
all of your program logic becomes pure
pure functions so let me do actually
have another example of that I need to
just check me find you okay I won't go
through but essentially you write your
model in a functional way you write your
model update in a functional way you
write your view in a functional way and
then you give it all to the the host
system whether it's Elm or fabulous or
fable or whichever system you're using
and you can apply functional programming
to the entire to both your server side
and your aunt your and to your client
side a very powerful way of approaching
you is and I'm really if you're into
functional and you do some web
programming I really encourage you to
check out fable and and szostak which
take this approach model view update
approach I've also been take a pliant
approach to to xamarin development so
you can use this kind of functional
approach to xamarin xamarin forms
development through a system called
fabulous so please check that out as
well there's just some examples of some
apps built using fabulous this one
contacts one it's a great sample showing
you how to do database access web
requests and the like as well as
integrating with xamarin essentials and
this one over here is showing you how
you can integrate third-party components
for you know for 3d as well okay so the
the next one composition you'll see
examples like this for composing the top
end of a program again each phase of
this is in sort of entirely functional
lexing parsing binding optimizing code
gen mapping another
optimizing phase Ibaka in phase and then
finishing the compiler and it's the fact
that the top-end composition of your
program just ends up looking like
composition is is lovely and you see
that in the quote from Bou Craig there
feels giddy people giddy smiles when
people see it and I'd already mentioned
giraffe which takes a similar approach
to composition for the top-end of web
requests so you can see that it's
developed defining a web app and using
this compositional dsl to choose to the
different routes urls index login user
and so on and then the the the logout
implementation up above so you can apply
that compositional approach both to the
front end to the back end and to your
things like your compilers and
transformers if you're writing okay if
stuff kind of like but I've said that if
not all code is good code it better
watch your time okay and sometimes
you'll see this kind of code now you
know F sharp library doesn't come with
these two functions but most functional
language implementations do and I left
them out on purpose because they don't
like them and you I've literally seen
people this these things take a curried
version of the function or the thing
that takes the arguments sort of
iteratively to one that takes the
arguments is a tuple and you'll see that
people sometimes define these functions
and do this kind of weird thing in
dotnet when you can just write that okay
and there's absolutely no point in in
doing that and I might also use
something like uncarrier here and it's
two indecipherable far too often and you
just write write things out explicitly
about what what is happening and so
there's a there's a set of funk or e
allure abstract kind of things in in
functional programming which we
deliberately leave out of F sharp and if
you working in teams where the the F
sharp guy or woman lady defines those
functions and starts using them then
just say no we I don't think we should
do that in this
please we we don't we can't read your
code when you write that sort of thing
so just just don't don't do it there's
also a back pipe operator and F sharp
which actually leads to some really
weird code like this kind of thing which
and I I mean just don't use it okay
it doesn't help anyone I should never
have put it in all right I mean in a
cage there are a couple of places you
can use it it's okay but on the whole
it's just like just just don't just say
no yeah so never ever use it and
especially don't use it in beginner code
you're not doing anyone a favor and
don't ever put these things on the same
line it looks like a TIE fighter from
Star Wars on top and it's like just
don't yeah
there are even these weird operators
which you really please don't use ever
they should not have been included and
they should be deprecated it once we
find a proper way to really deprecated
things that Microsoft is happy with now
the next one is a point free code you'll
often see people doing this add to 10
list map + 10 or times 2 plus 1 for
double and increment just don't write
this sort of thing
so just avoid this needless point free
code and just write out the functions as
functions please not so so Eric's a
pilot has a great line about this there
are rare cases where point 3 dear cells
that are legible in the large and I
actually did show you one of those
earlier in context of web programming
but just adopting this approach it
carries a big burden of proof okay and
you can say that to your people in your
team you're saying look I'm looking at
that F sharp code you're writing you're
trying to do point free kind of style
and just so don't you know why what is
it really bringing value to this team
and please this kid make your code
clearer F sharp code can be extremely
clear and and you should write it like
that and of course giving proper names
to things is part of that so you'll also
see a lot of use of fold in some
functional programming languages now F
sharp actually de-emphasizes folds a lot
so instead you do the actual sum by max
player choose try pick
map fold or reduce some specific more
specific operation fold is like a blunt
instrument like a go-to in your code
it's often extremely hard to understand
what a fold is actually doing so if you
so so use these more specific operators
please skip on there now I'm running a
little bit of time do i yeah I'm sure
they're gonna call time with me I might
go a couple of minutes over so okay just
to say records actually we'll skip the
part of that records and talk about
objects okay so if does support
object-oriented programming you have
these inputs here and we have these
objectives two internals here exported
properties and exported methods this is
a fully functional object okay there's
no actual state here it's effectively
just taking the imports getting some
derived computation and then publishing
those in various ways and these are the
core features that we have we have class
types interface types and these object
expressions so F sharp object oriented
programming can be used extremely well
in this kind of way here's some part of
some positive thing which is taking the
kernels and doing a whole lot of
computations and then publishing them
exactly what I showed before just in a
little bit more richer a different kind
of setting functional computation
encapsulated inside objects now the
problem with object-oriented programming
and we this when we did the F sharp
language design I remember sitting down
with Dominic Cooney who's from Australia
from Brisbane who's an intern with me
and we started to really kind of
deconstruct oo and I was is actually
loads of different features right from
the dot notation all the way down to
aspect or into programming or or other
ideas that have come out of the
object-oriented community the question
is what do you kind of do with all of
these you really need them all and some
of these like I think calling time yeah
I've got a whole 20 minutes Wow man
they're generous okay good then I can
slow down
so so some of these things what are they
all about all these ideas that have come
from the object-oriented kind of
tradition well some of them are about a
better API language some of them make a
chef a better implementation language
some of them are part of a new Interop
standard some of them we can just kind
of adore so it's we we affect them
effectively kind of did that bit by bit
we came to a stable characterization
where you're not going down the slippery
slope in a sense you're not you can draw
lines about object-oriented features and
these are the lines that I draw so let's
run through these so the basic use of
the dot notation is something that F
sharp embraces you can go X dot length
now if you know other functional
languages that's not always true rather
for other functional languages but F
sharp is quite happy to say look I know
what the type of X is I can work out
what the length is what's being resolved
by dot length by that name and we can
use the dot notation quite happily with
a couple of type annotations and that of
course means we need to have instance
members and methods and that is what I
called type directive name resolution
and you've already seen this notion of
implicit constructor that allows you to
have the inputs to the object at the top
and then these let bindings and then
these members and that that's a part of
the object-oriented tradition as well
static members index and notation named
arguments optional arguments interface
types and implementations now all of
these things are fit absolutely fine in
the context of functional
object-oriented programming you could
you put all of these things into a
Haskell and it would just work
absolutely just fine
so we can absolutely embrace these as
part of functional programming and it's
an important a lot of micro decisions
are made in F sharp to make these things
work very well while also keeping the
core goodness of functional programming
there is a range of things that are
exceptionally useful in practice but you
need to be a little bit cautious about
how you
you use them in F sharp but you learn to
use them tastefully there's the whole
idea that you can actually mutate data
in F sharp you can do side effects it is
an imperative language but with a
functional first kind of emphasis then
you can find operators order properties
you can implement these standards like a
disposable ienumerable into type
extensions don't note things like events
trucks delegates in arms and typecasting
so we use those where necessary use them
kind of respectfully sparingly there's
kind of got to be rationale for using
those things and then there's sort of
set of things which F sharp F sharp
programming really D emphasizes and
probably the most important one for the
c-sharp programmers to know about is
that F sharp really D emphasizes of the
use of large type hierarchies now a
c-sharp has already de-emphasized that
compared to Java okay one of the great
things that C shoppers did I think was
to say we don't need to just you know
hierarchically classify our animals cats
and dogs and everything into in all the
way through our code this is like once
you give programmers a tool to do
hierarchical classification it's like
they go crazy they just start
classifying everything's and that's
where you get that abstract class
factory being whatever sort of things
you see in Java and it's it's like some
part of the human psychology or
something that once we once we can
classify things we just love to love to
do it it's like so so f sharp doesn't do
that we have very small type hierarchies
in F sharp you can see from some of the
language constructs I've shown before
that you can do domain modeling without
defining zillions of types to just
define one one type with all the
different cases so so large type
hierarchies are not a big thing and that
also means we massively de-emphasize
implementation inheritance you can
occasionally do it for performance
reasons or for some kind of modeling
reasons often in the core of a library
but on the whole we don't do it sort of
hidden away but we don't do
implementation inheritance you share
is a much F sharp object oriented
programming has a much stronger emphasis
on dela on delegation then
implementation inheritance for sharing
and it's really important to understand
that what problems implementation and
inheritance
caused and the thing about
implementation inheritance is you're
always taking something that's already
complex and making it more complex okay
and that's like that's the that's the
nature of it you and you can't hide that
complexity way like you can with
delegation so please delegate don't use
implementation inheritance it Knowles an
objective field of and a really heavy
use of method overloading is also sort
of that's down the object rabbit hole
and we don't go there very often in F
sharp and we have to have exceptionally
good reason to do it then we have a set
of things which we don't support at all
technical things curried method
overloads self-types wildcard types
aspect to our into programming or
whatever and you can just they're not
supported so roughly speaking you'll of
the first set please you tolerate the
second set you mostly avoid the second
third set and you absolutely forget all
about the fourth set and the difference
there is really between object
programming and object oriented
programming F sharp absolutely supports
object programming inspire you can see
from this that if the first set and to
some extent the second set what object
programming is about there's a major
part of the F sharp methodology and you
and you have to be good at object
programming to be a good F sharp
programmer but we don't we don't really
embrace object-oriented programming we
support object program but we support
sequence programming as well is it
support async programming there's many
different kind of computational
structures that all flow together and
work nicely in in in F sharp and that
doesn't mean you have to obsessively
think about classification and object
orientation for every part of your code
so what's the difference
object
programming focuses on these things
encoding notational convenience API
organ omits yeah we loved the dotnet
design guidelines they're they're great
now and we should you you should know
them and learn them as an f-sharp
programmer good naming practical and
capsulation small composable
abstractions and this thing at the
bottom making simple things out of
potentially complex foundations that's
absolutely key object-oriented
programming a next extreme is sort of
this sort of dogmas you know
everything's an object
we must hire it's the sort of page pages
one to ten of the object or at a
programming book okay hierarchical
classification is at the center of how
we think large abstractions are often
with many many holes and nulls and
failure points and exceptions and under
under lamented methods and tends to
focus on declarations not expressions
and composition through hierarchies and
you can this is not what we're F sharp
lands this is what we this is where we
land embrace object programming and make
it fit with a expression oriented typed
functional programming paradigm okay so
just to say there's some other really
magical parts of F sharp one of them is
is type providers I showed you an
example of this earlier I'll flick back
to it rather than trying to load up a
web browser that probably won't connect
it was in here so the first use to this
is that the is HTML provider and this is
one of the most magically and under
unknown parts of the F sharp magic and
this is where you can point the an F
sharp type provider at a URL and it will
do analysis of the data on that and
schema on that on that URL and then give
you the contents of that back in a
strongly typed way without any more code
so you can see the tables dot version
history is extracting one of the tables
out of that out of that URL
and then you get strong completion and
typing into our dot minor version and if
you look at that actual webpage you'll
see that it's table has a column heading
called minor version and so you're
actually doing sort of where screen
scraping strongly type screen scraping
without ever because we've got this
typewriter that is doing the schemer
analysis on that page at compile time to
allow us to do strongly typed
programming against it
you can also snapshot a page is the
sample schema for that it's also type
providers for CSV and for Jason and many
and for databases and men for as vo
table storage as a storage type provider
you can disappoint your pointer of data
script directly at your as your as a
storage and you get a strongly typed
access through to everything on those
everything that you can access through
that okay so it's giving forward again
sorry okay now if chef has another
feature called computation expressions
so and you'll sometimes in functional
languages you'll see this kind of code
and this is not good FF code it's like
list.com cat entities this filter list
filter filter collect cons filter filter
filter and so on all to make a list and
butter shop has a language feature that
makes that code much more clear and it
allows you to write it out using for
loops it's all functional it's a
functional translation underneath but
you'll you know for ian's entities yield
that one for these generic parameters if
that yield that and you can see how much
clearer that code is even though it's
actually logically equivalent to that
code before so this is called a
computation expression so it's a list
expression where you're computing a list
as you go it's a bit like c-sharp
enumerators enumerator methods but you
can use it into the expression like this
in any expression form and you can use
it to create arrays
and on-demand sequences and and other
other structures so the same feature is
used for async code so you'll see here
you know the server is async this the
client is I think that the browser is
async this with some sort of sleep in
there and then we put those in parallel
and we we run those things and so these
act like tasks now I think is the lovely
programming paradigm and one of the
great things is a cancellation tokens
flow implicit through implicitly
throughout this whole program but it
does have if not as performant as tasks
and in F sharp 5.0 we're going to be
putting in native support for tasks
curly using a similar using F sharp
computation expressions as well and one
of the amazing things about F sharp of
computational expressions is we've been
able to do so many things with them and
yet all you know very the async tasks
the computations I've shown before
sequences async sequences things that
they're putting in one by one into
c-sharp we kind of get them all for free
from this more general kind of mechanism
and we're we're getting the performance
side of things for tasks sorted out to
be on par with c-sharp tasks in the next
version of F sharp so you can do icing
sequences for example it's in a library
you know acing sequence with the sleep
and yield and sleep and yield and and
similarly yield this while true take
asleep and and yield another date first
for an it for for a stream of dates and
that library is after I've controlled on
acing C but there are many other
examples of F sharp computation
expressions they're used to all sorts of
interesting interesting things okay so
just to finish off if good F sharp
practice it's it's not about functional
obscurity it's about writing great clear
coded code that could be debugged
commented tested that his profile its
profile is performant under CI and it is
readable we fully embraced
software these all these aspects of
software engineering methodology and
don't ever let people think that it's
about just about sort of approach and
it's about writing obscure code it's the
opposite it's about writing
crystal-clear code that conveys the
intent and lets you focus on your domain
rather than on the on the details of
programming okay so I will I'll close
there if Java emphasizes clear code to
solve real-world problems
absolutely the sender of the F sharp
code I love it's always been our
description of F sharp clear succinct
code to solve real world problems not
all functional code is good code not all
object-oriented code is good code and
object programming is different to
object-oriented programming and thank
you very much and yeah I guess we've got
time for some requests for some
questions thank you
[Applause]
time for questions or do we don't not
taking questions in the talk we can take
a couple of couple of questions maybe
anyway yeah
yep oh okay so the f-sharp invented to
some extent there's a long history towed
the idea of racing programming but it
essentially invented the idea or that to
turn code into async code you just had
to put async early around your code or
the c-sharp equivalent of those just put
a weight into your code and it becomes a
sink now F sharp made that invention and
delivered it as part of F sharp in his
first version and then the C sharp team
put in its version of of async in terms
of tasks okay and then the rest of the
world has gone on to add a a single task
support into the various languages now
the F sharp approach does do is really
very nice to encourage you to look at
the paper called the F sharp
asynchronous programming model and it it
and also Thomas Thomas Patrick's
material on on the differences between
the F sharp and C sharp systems a key
thing in the F sharp is that in the F
sharp system is that the cancellation
tokens are propagated implicitly okay so
you don't have in C sharp you'll always
be facing is very nice but you'll always
see it's explicit plumbing of this
cancellation tokens all the way through
it's done implicitly you can't you means
it's a whole range of mistakes you can't
make with regard to cancellation that
does come up with with a performance
cost in that there's a there's a there's
a two-stage process for activating an
f-sharp async you compose them and then
activate them and it just means that you
can't quite get the same level of
performance as you can with tasks so in
practice we do need tasks support and
they are different types for they
interoperate very seamlessly casing to
task and a single from task and so I
think the best resolution to that is
this put it straight into the F shell
language into the compiler and make sure
we get the same performance
characteristics as a sous-chef code and
I've been working a lot of that lately
it will be a jitter more general
mechanism we'll make sure it works for
face for task sequences as well state
machine compilation of those and also
user-defined computational structures
tasks like things which can benefit from
so I've always state machine or
resumable code okay so another question
anyone else okay I think we're done min
thank you very much
[Applause]